Dave Goldberg was one of Silicon
Valley's best and most beloved
entrepreneurs one of the most genuine
CEOs I've ever met a man of fierce
intelligence a proud and supportive
husband of his wife Sheryl Sandberg a
doting father of two children a loyal
friend and colleague and a dear friend
of our show his life was cut too short
but every day fully lived we wanted to
take a moment to remember him I want to
welcome our special guest host for the
hour Dave Goldberg CEO of SurveyMonkey
thanks so much for joining us today
you better be here your hour of fame
Stephane SurveyMonkey CEO Dave Goldberg
joins us now with more in our monthly
segment the SurveyMonkey shakedown
I took my first company public we had
you know ten million in revenue we
weren't profitable there are lots of
companies that went public really early
they use the public markets to raise
capital now you know all the bankers
they would like to take country slowly
but they tell you if you don't have a
billion dollar valuation don't even
waste your time I have a long background
on my music and for a long time we were
the upstarts and now's streaming and
particularly Pandora in this case for
online music is his mainstream you know
when I was a kid I built model rockets
you know a drone is way cooler than a
model rocket
if I can just push a button and call a
self-driving car I think that's like the
ultimate sort of Jetsons future we all
want to see
tributes have been pouring in on
Goldberg's Facebook page and on Twitter
they paint the picture of a talented
leader compassionate a sharp businessman
sincere universally adored a man who was
kind and good and generous with his
advice and with his time as he was with
me and with us in one of his last posts
on facebook Goldberg talked about how
proud he was of his wife for leading the
fight for gender equality at home and at
work he was a leader in that fight too
and he led by example we'll miss you
Dave but boy is this world better
because you were in it